UKRAINE IS FACING ITS --
FOR WORKING EFFECTIVELY AS
RUSSIA LAUNCHES ITS FIRST WAVE
OF DRONE ATTACKS ON KYIV IN
WEEKS.
UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT, VOLODYMYR
ZELENSKYY, SAYS HE'S PROUD THAT
ALL 13 DRONES WERE SHUTDOWNS IN
WEDNESDAY'S ATTACKS, TWO
BUILDINGS AND HOUSE WERE
DAMAGED.
UKRAINE HAS LONG BEEN ASKING --
PATRIOT MISSILE DEFENSE SYSTEM.
NOW THE WHITE HOUSE TOWELS CNN
THAT IT'S FINALIZING PLANS TO
DO SO.
THE KREMLIN SAYS, IF THAT
HAPPENS, THE SYSTEM WOULD BE A
LEGITIMATE TARGET FOR RUSSIA.
>> CNN'S NATIONAL --
HE IS ON THE GROUND IN KYIV,
AND HE HAS THE LATEST FROM THAT
UKRAINIAN --
>> PEOPLE WERE WOKEN UP TO THE
SOUND OF EXPLOSIONS IN THE
EARLY MORNING HOUR IN KYIV, A
SHORT DISTANCE FROM WHERE I'M
STANDING.
SOME PEOPLE WERE UP ALREADY
GETTING READY FOR WORK, WHEN WE
HEARD THAT A VERY VERY
DISTINCTIVE SOUND OF THE DRONE
ENGINES FOLLOWED BY EXPLOSIONS.
ONE OF THE DRONES ACTUALLY
CAUSED A HUGE HOLE INSIDE OF A
BUILDING.
THERE WAS DAMAGE, PEOPLE HAD
THEIR IMPORTANT WINDOWS
SHATTERED.
YET, REMARKABLY THE TRAIN
MILITARY SAYS THAT IN THIS
DRONE ATTACK, ON KYIV, THE
FIRST IN A NUMBER OF WEEKS,
HERE IN THE CENTRAL AREA, THERE
HAS BEEN NO SIGNIFICANT DAMAGE
TO THE POWER GRID ON TOP OF
WHAT THEY'RE ALREADY DEALING
WITH.
THERE ARE ROLLING BLACKOUTS
CONTINUOUSLY, AFFECTING PEOPLE
WHO LIVE HERE IN, KEEP.
ALSO AFFECTING PEOPLE WHO LIVE
ALL OVER UKRAINE.
THE POWER GRID IS FAR FROM
STABLE.
IT'S GOING TO BE QUITE SOME
TIME, AS CREWS CONTINUE TO WORK
TO TRY TO REPAIR THESE
FACILITIES THAT ARE
CONTINUOUSLY DAMAGED BY THESE
RUSSIAN ATTACKS, WEAPONIZING,
WINTERTIME HARD DURING THE
POWER GRID.
--
THE START OF WINTER IS JUST
DAYS AWAY.
EVEN THOUGH IN THIS INSTANCE,
THE UKRAINIANS DID SHOOT DOWN,
THEY SAY, 13 DRONES FIRED FROM
RUSSIA.
THESE ARE IRANIAN MADE DRONES
THAT EXPLODE UPON IMPACT.
THERE WERE INCIDENTS, JUST IN
THAT LAST WEEK, OR SOME OF THE
JOHNSTON MAKE IT THROUGH.
FOR EXAMPLE, THE SOUTHERN
UKRAINIAN REGION IN ODESSA, ONE
AND A HALF MILLION PEOPLE WERE
PLUNGED INTO DARKNESS LAST
WEEKEND WHEN OUT OF 15 DRONES
THAT WERE LAUNCHED BY RUSSIA,
FIVE OF THEM DID HIT THEIR
TARGETS.
THEY WERE CERTAINLY WELCOME
NEWS HERE IN KYIV THAT THE
REPORTING BY CNN THAT THE
PATRIOT MISSILE DEFENSE SYSTEM
WILL BE ARRIVING AT SOME POINT
IN THIS COUNTRY.
BUT OF COURSE, THAT COMES WITH
ITS OWN SET OF CHALLENGES AND
RISK, INCLUDING THREATS FROM
THE RUSSIANS THAT THIS WILL
MAKE NATO, AND THE UNITED
STATES, COMPLICIT IN ESCALATING
THIS WAR.
WILL RIPLEY, CNN, KYIV.
>>> THE WHITE HOUSE IS
FINALIZING A PACKAGE TO SEND THE
PATRIOT MISSILE TO UKRAINE.
AN OFFICIAL ANNOUNCEMENT COULD
KM THIS WEEK.
IT NEEDS TO BE APPROVED BY ROY
AUSTIN.
SCOTT McCLAIN HAS THE LATEST ON
THIS FOR US.
SCOTT, HOW WOULD THIS MAKE A
DIFFERENCE ON THE BATTLEFIELD
FOR UKRAINE.
>> Reporter: CHRISTINE, THE
UKRAINIANS HAVE BEEN ASKING FOR
MONTHS FOR NATO ALLIES TO SEND
MORE ADVANCED AIR DEFENSE
SYSTEMS, ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE
ATTACKS ON ITS INFRASTRUCTURE AS
OF LATE.
THE SYSTEMS IT HAS ALREADY,
THOSE SEEM TO DO JUST FINE.
THERE WAS A BARRAGE OF DRONES
AIMED AT KYIV AND ACCORDING TO
ZE ZELENSKYY, IT HIT BUILDINGS
AROUND THE CITY AND HOMES.
IT'S NOT CLEAR WHAT THE TARGET
WAS.
PERHAPS WE HAVE A CLUE AS TO
WHAT THE MOTIVATION MAY HAVE
BEEN, AT LEAST ACCORDING TO
UKRAINIAN TELEVISION.
IT HAD ONE OF THE FRAGMENTS THAT
HAD AN INSCRIPTION ON IT
REFERRING TO A DRONE STRIKE
EARLIER.
AS FOR THE PATRIOT MISSILE
SYSTEM THAT UKRAINE HAS BEEN
GIVEN SINCE THE OUTSET OF THE
WAR.
THE DIFFERENCE IS THAT IT HAS
THE ABILITY TO SHOOT DOWN
INCOMING DRONES, ROCKETS,
AIR
AIRCRAFT.
THEY HAD A FURTHER DISTANCE
WHICH MEANS POTENTIALLY YOU
COULD STRIKE DOWN THE TARGETS
FARTHER AWAY FROM THE INTENDED
TARGETS.
YOU WOULDN'T HAVE THE KIND OF
SITUATION WE HAVE THIS MORNING
IN KYIV POTENTIALLY WHERE YOU
HAVE FRAGMENTS OF THE MISSILES
OR DRONES OR WHAT HAVE YOU DOING
DAMAGE IN THE CITY.
THE DIFFICULTY IS IT TAKES A
LARGE CREW TO OPERATE AND DOZENS
OF PEOPLE AND THE TRAINING ON
THIS SYSTEM, IT TAKES MONTHS.
NOW THE U.S. HAS THIS CHALLENGE
OF TRYING TO TRAIN UP UKRAINIAN
TROOPS THAT WILL BE USING THIS
SYSTEM AT ITS AIRBASE IN
GERMANY.
AS I SAID, NORMALLY IT TAKES
MONTHS.
THEY'RE GOING TO TRY TO CONDENSE
THAT DOWN TO AS LITTLE TIME AS
POSSIBLE.
>> SCOTT McCLAIN, THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THAT.